noch nicht ausgegangen ist es her da hat
julian paulina die sie besucht und
gelernt wie man nett und kocht und putzt
das habe ganz gut geklappt diese uns
wissen vielleicht auch so war er auch in
dieser hinsicht etwas reifer wie andere
gleichaltrige
beim songschreiben jedenfalls ist erst
unter dem namen farbe macht er musik wie
ein besessener das mit 24 jahren
fahrbach könnte ein ganz großer werden
[Musik]
sein ruf reicht schon weit über den
heimischen zürcher kreis 4 hinaus ein
neuer teil unterarm dazu seine lieder
leidenschaftlich und lebensklug dann
kann sich positiv gemeint werden das
zeigt dass mir das in den quelle vom
band aus aber wird klar
zum teil werden die jungen verfügung
gestellt
eine jugendliche verweigerungshaltung
hat er sich jedenfalls bewahrt gefällt
sich abseits vom geschehen der weil er
in seinen texten voll angreift
[Musik]
er spielt mit ironie und provokation hat
ein gewinnendes äußeres und die richtige
artikel vom jungen bob dylan ist die
rede
alle medien wollen dabei kommt sein
debütalbum heraus
[Musik]
und wenn du liegen
lillifee
[Musik]
eine lange wie tradition klingt er an
von jacques brel bis zur heutigen balkan
die virtuos diebe hans-karl badisch der
frontseite radikal wie er ist hat er
alles auf die karte musik und forderte
sofort mit einem gas für den empfänger
und absender das wenn mega fokussiert
[Musik]
eigentlich hat er den liedermacher ja
schon im blut
sein vater der sizilianer pippo pollina
machte von der schweiz aus groß kariert
herkunft soll aber möglichst kein thema
sein
eine bewusste abgrenzung vom vater der
familie aber gibt es nicht
eigenständig traditionell und doch
modern und er hat seine ganz persönliche
sprache entwickeln die poetisch wie
politisch ist
[Musik]
ein
eine klare politische haltung für ihn
selbstverständlich
diese fordert er auch von erfahrenen
musiker kollegen ein die ein größeres
publikum erreichen wie etwa blick
[Musik]
es wäre halt aber zieht das etwa
anderswo position hat gar nix im blick
und mitarbeiter prognose an statt
da ich ja gar nicht so informiert und
weiter fließt natürlich durch das bild
frei auf der immer wieder zeitig treibt
sich eben gern an der weg da muss auch
einmal eine gut gemeinte lieben freiheit
dran glaubt aber ein versprechen
[Musik]
juli stabil was ich euch erste bilanz